[موسيقى]
بنفس الاسلوب قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تدخل
البلده القديمه من نابلس تتبعها عشرات
الاليات العسكريه القوات الخاصه حاصرت
منزلا في حاره القريون والاليات الثقيله
حاصرت البلده القديمه من نابلس مباشره عن
اتجهنا نحو حمزه وغم وربطو ممكن نوعا ما
اخدعون لا تحقيق عزله بغرفه بغرفه معينه
تقريبا اعدوا تقريبا ساعه ولبين ما يقول
لي انهن خرجوا وانسحبوا من المنطقه
اشتباكات مسلحه رافقت اقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لنابلس اسفرت عن اصابه جندي
اسرائيلي
وثلاثه عشر فلسطينيا بالرصاص وسبعين
بالاختناق جراء استنشاق الغاز المسيلي
للدموع اضافه الى اعتقال فلسطينيين تقول
اسرائيل انهما هدف العمليه رغم ان العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اليوم في نابلس لم
توقع ضحايا الا انها تعيد التاكيد ان
الفعل ورده الفعل تبقي دوامه العنف دائره
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من حاره القريون في
البلده القديمه بنابلس خالد القاسم
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات